hey this is really funny so yesterday
Bernie Sanders did a town hall on Fox
News again this was his second Fox News
Town Hall this election cycle and the
last time that Fox News did this it
wasn't really great for them they kept
trying to set up Bernie to fail
countless times the crowd was with
Bernie the Fox host seemed almost
punch-drunk they were getting slammed
with applause for Bernie's ideas from
the audience left and right but this
time Fox News came a little bit more
prepared they knew Bernie had to do this
Town Hall because he's losing in
Michigan badly they did the Town Hall in
Michigan on the eve of the Michigan
primary and they were prepared to go
after Bernie about the cost of his plans
and all sorts of different issues and
that's fair game that's policy but the
crowd did not like a lot of the
questions from the hosts bret baier and
martha maccallum and at one point at
multiple points but most notably at one
point which we're going to look at they
boo martha maccallum and the
conversation was about the cost of
health care and Bernie's Medicare for
all plan and one of the biggest
deceptions around the Medicare for all
plan as proposed by Bernie is all about
taxes will go up taxes will go up and
Bernie points out well listen taxes will
go up but then you won't be paying an
average of twelve thousand a year in
premiums co-pays deductibles
out-of-pocket expenses on and on and on
so you'll pay a four percent tax on
income above twenty nine thousand which
means for someone earning $60,000 twelve
hundred and forty dollars but you won't
pay any of that other stuff right and
Martha pulls out this but what about all
the people making thirty and forty grand
a year who like their current employer
sponsored for-profit plan and this was
just too much for the audience to bear
because of course almost nobody who is
earning thirty or forty thousand dollars
and has health insurance from their
employer which is not everybody is happy
with their plan and if you don't and
you're buying a plan from healthcare.gov
or in Massachusetts the massachusetts
health connector or whatever you're
almost certainly not happy with the plan
and check this out the crowd just booing
Martha so let's say you pay twelve
hundred two thousand dollars more in
taxes for comprehensive health care but
you're not paying twelve thousand
dollars in premiums co-payments and
out-of-pocket expenses who has
but a deal well that may be true for the
$12,000 a year person for the 30 or
$40,000 a year per person who likes the
health plan they have from their from
their employer yeah so very much a crowd
not happy with martha maccallum and it's
so funny to see these bernie town halls
blow up in the faces of fox news not
that it really matters because again
most of the people voting in the
Democratic primaries aren't watching
these anyway but they never go after
Bernie on the real issue with his health
care payment plan so when they come in
and they say but what about all the
people making thirty and forty K who
like their plans and Bernie will take it
away that's a bad argument most people
hate their plans most people earning
thirty or forty thousand have terrible
plans that they pay too much for if you
really want to have a serious adult
conversation with Bernie about the
issues with his plan then talk about the
fact that Bernie's plan assumes drastic
reductions to health care spending per
person and doesn't explain how we will
get there Bernie actually said it during
the town hall he said we spend twice as
much as other countries on health care
health care as Bernie says and he will
fix it with Medicare for all his plan
doesn't actually explain how do you cut
spending by 50 percent on a per person
basis and that's where his plan falters
I would respect Fox more if they want to
go after Bernie for holes in his plan
don't go after the raising people's
taxes thing the average person making
sixty thousand will pay twelve forty and
they're gonna avoid paying premiums cope
it with that it's a dumb argument it's
been debunked countless times they will
pay less than they currently do that's
how you play a superficial gotcha game
actually dig into well hold on a second
profit is only a few percent for health
insurance companies that won't save you
the 50 percent that your plan assumes
how will you cut medical spending per
person by 50 percent in order to make
your plans costs balance out that's a
more serious inquiry into Bernie's plan
and many plans right how do you get to
the numbers that you assume going after
you know people who make 30 grand love
their plans and you're going
take them that is not a serious inquiry
into the plan of Bernie Sanders I've got
something really cool today the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video